merci isabelle bonjour à toutes et à
tous j'ai donc le plaisir et l'honneur
d'animer cette première table ronde ont
consacré à l'avenir au financement de
notre modèle social vaste question
modèle social bien sûr qui concerne le
succès au sud aussi bien par dont le
sujet des retraites que de la santé qui
sera abordé dans la deuxième table ronde
quelques chiffres en guise
d'introduction il faut savoir que
d'après lé ocde les dépenses sociales
rentrer en france comme l'a rappelé
isabelle 32 à 34 % du pib national
c'est à dire dix points de plus que la
moyenne de l'oscd e et 10 points de plus
qu'en 1982 ce sont 600 20 milliards
d'euros qui sont dépensés chaque année
240 4 milliards d'euros pour les
retraites 235 milliards d'euros pour la
santé et ces chiffres sont là pour nous
rappeler notamment que ces dépenses
sociales sont envolés notamment à partir
de 1981 l'arrivée de la gauche au
pouvoir et on le voit aujourd'hui il y à
de vrais défis devant nous concerne la
protection sociale alors qu'il concerne
pas forcément la politique familiale
dont le rapport coût bénéfice est assez
positif mais les vrais défis ils seront
abordés tout au long de cette matinée
concerne bien sûr la retraite est
également la santé alors malgré toutes
ces dépenses
on le voit assez considérable notre
modèle social est à bout de souffle
nous avons fêté il y a quelques mois
l'anniversaire des 70 ans
notre système de protection sociale un
système qui a très peu évolué depuis
1945 il ya que notre société a muté
depuis ses nombreuses années comme
trouver le social ne s'est pas forcément
adaptée aux défis de la société
les résultats sont là en tout cas les
chiffres sont également là pour le
montrer 25 % des jeunes sont au chômage
un record depuis 1997 20% d'entre eux
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
le nombre de travailleurs pauvres
explose et dans le domaine de la santé
il y à des inégalités qui reste encore
importante alors des choses ont été
faites et notamment
l'or en 2010 avec la réforme portée par
eric woerth de la réforme des retraites
la réforme de l'assurance-maladie
également en 2004 il y a eu la loi hpst
de roselyne bachelot
mais en tout cas toutes ces réformes
montre une chose c'est qu'il est assez
difficile aujourd'hui d'atteindre les
résultats en tout cas souhaité et
notamment ce fameux retour à l'équilibré
alors trois leviers trois leviers de la
réforme notre modèle social
premier levier c'est bien sur
l'efficience du système puisque le
modèle social français est victime
notamment de son fonctionnement et des
fraudes sociales sujets abordés par
claude greff
il y a également deuxième levier la
responsabilité des acteurs aussi bien
dans le domaine bien sûr de la retraite
avec la retraite responsable et garant
de propositions qui sont faites
notamment dans les dents des réformes
dit paramétrique pour retrouver
continuent à retrouver l'équilibré de
notre système de retraite dans le
domaine de la santé on peut pas
d'automédication de la prévention
individuelle et puis ce fameux virage
ambulatoire qui va permettre également
de répondre responsabiliser les acteurs
troisième levier chez la jeunesse car
pour garantir la solidarité
intergénérationnelle qui est aujourd'hui
le socle notre système de protection
sociale et notamment bien sûr dans le
domaine des retraites il faut remettre
la jeunesse et les jeunes au coeur de
notre système
car c'est cette jeunesse qui va assurer
le financement de demain alors quelques
idées là encore le développement de la
formation professionnelle dès le collège
la création d'un fonds souverain dédiés
à l'insertion des jeunes
c'est à dire d'avant la création d'une
caisse nationale d'investissement
jeunesse pour financer la formation et
les jeunes entrepreneurs
évidemment d'autres idées existent c'est
l'objet de cette première table ronde
est en tout cas pour nous parler de tous
ces leviers financiers du système social
nous accueillons avec plaisir et je vais
leur demander de venir de me rejoindre
sur la tribune julien d'amont julien
d'amont qui est professeur associé à
sciences po fondateur et dirigeant de la
société de conseil d'étude est clair
bienvenue mais
si votre présence frédéric bizarre
économiste spécialisé dans les questions
notamment sociales et de santé
frédéric blizzard est également ancien
enseignant pardon à sciences po paris
j'invite également mes côtés bernard
accoyer député maire d'annecy
ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale médecin de profession et qui
est membre de la commission des affaires
sociales à l'assemblée cher bernard
merci de nous rejoindre et merci d'avoir
répondu positivement à notre invitation
eric woerth que je tiens excuses et
qu'il va qui va nous rejoindre dans
quelques minutes puisqu'il ils étaient
sûrs dans une sur une matinale ce matin
sur lci donc il va nous rejoindre dans
quelques minutes alors sans plus tarder
je passe la parole à julien d'amont qui
va nous faire part de sa réflexion quant
au levier possible concerne le
financement notre protection sociale
merci à vous merci de cette invitation
alors si j'avais pu vous projeter
quelque chose je vous aurais projeter
quelque chose qui vous aurait fait
plaisir c'est une photo de nicolas
sarkozy
en 2009 nous avions une couverture de
the economist un hebdomadaire
britannique libérale donc honni en
france et nous avions il nous aime pas
une fois peu près une couverture par an
sur la france une couverture sur le
modèle social français que voyons-nous
sur cette couverture
nous voyons le président de la
république de l'époque toisant la
chancelière allemande et regardons de
très haut sans mépris le chancelier
pardon le premier ministre britannique
gordon brown qui était au fond du trou
et la légende était le modèle social
célébrant ainsi le modèle social
français qui est un formidable
amortisseur de crise et le problème qui
nous fait discuter aujourd'hui c'est que
c'était également un amortisseur de deux
reprises les grands chiffres qui ont été
proposées par arnaud robinet en effet la
france c'est à peu près le tiers de son
pib affectés à la protection sociale
c'est pas 620 milliards d'euros + c'est
plus de 700 milliards d'euros et si on
regarde ça d'une autre manière aussi
plus étranges
la france est moins de 1% de la
population mondiale mais c'est environ
12 % de la dépense sociale
dial mais à la rigueur pourquoi pas
c'est pas grave on peut même imaginer
qu'on puisse socialiser davantage encore
la dépense le problème ce qu'ils y
allaient des déficits l'inefficience les
les inégalités alors ceux ci prononcés
notre modèle social je pense se
caractérise par quatre défis mais le mot
le truc à la mode c'est à dire
aujourd'hui que ce sont 4 p parce qu'on
est confronté à quatre transformations
avec un modèle qui doit devenir plus
préventif alors tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir
mais qu'il s'agisse de santé
d'investissement dans la jeunesse ce
sont des bascules dans les comptes des
bascules dans les organisations qui sont
annoncés depuis longtemps qu'il faudra
bien faire modèle social aussi va
reposer sur une dimension plus
prédictive et ça c'est très important en
matière de santé nos génie génétique
peuvent nous permettre de savoir les uns
les autres
ce à quoi plus probablement nous allons
être confrontés est ce que tout ceci va
déchirer la solidarité à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés certainement
techniquement le grand sujet de savoir
comment matière d'assurance on permet
aux gros risque d'être toujours couvert
de 3e p c'est que la protection sociale
va être plus personnalisés c'est pas la
sécurité sociale elle même le navire
amiral de la protection sociale qu'il
permet mais le monde des complémentaires
propose des contrats et des offres qui
vous permettre de mieux suivre de la
petite enfance jusqu'à la dépendance
l'ensemble de vos préoccupations et
solutions et on dit quatrième pc liés à
la révolution numérique que le modèle
social doit être plus participatif ça
c'est un gros sujet nous avons un
paritarisme un rien déclinante s'est
diplomatiquement 10 des représentants
des assurés sociaux qui les représentent
pas forcément très bien s'est
diplomatiquement dit aussi mais nous
allons de plus en plus pouvoir échanger
nous faisons les uns les autres
tout a changé en termes de participation
non plus voir un médecin sans être
passés auparavant sur internet pour voir
ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés comme
pathologie et ce à quoi nous pouvons
être confrontés comme posologie et le
mont des cats effet que
la mode de modèle social et transformé
mais alors sur le plan du financement
comme j'ai réfléchi à la question qui
nous a été posée je vous proposais ça va
être très court 4 c'est évidemment le
premier c'est que c'est contre un une
femme dans des contraintes considérables
aujourd'hui ça va à peu près tout le
monde se dit ah bah ça fait quarante ans
qu'on nous dit qu'on va dans le mur il
suffirait que les taux d'intérêt
augmentent un tout petit peu pour que le
mur aux seuls prennent véritablement en
pleine figure
immédiatement le deuxième c'est je pense
sur ce sujet du financement c'est que le
modèle social va être davantage coûteux
pourquoi parce que toujours nous aurons
à chercher individuellement pour notre
famille les pratiques médicales les
médicaments les plus performants et qui
vont nécessairement être à coûts plus
élevés il va en être de même pour les
retraites tout simplement parce que le
vieillissement et le vieillissement en
bonne santé et l'espérance de vie
grandissante font que sur les comptes
sociaux pèsent cette conséquence
positive système de protection sociale à
la française c'est qu'on vit mieux et
plus plus longtemps il ya troisième
cessé ces deux collectifs dans le dans
le financement
va-t-on davantage encore on est loin
d'aller loin dans ce domaine
individualiser la protection sociale par
des primes que l'on paierait
individuellement ou au contraire va
continuer va-t-on continuer avec ce
système on peut le dire peu de manière
provocante dans un milieu militant
socialiser collectiviser mais le grand
sujet c'est jusqu'où va t'en aller dans
et avec quel équilibre entre ce qui
relève véritablement de la protection
collective et de la protection
individuelle
enfin quatrième dossier sur lequel on
discutera j'imagine beaucoup dans la
médecine et c'est le cde contributif
est-ce que nous allons financer notre
système de protection sociale par des
contributions de type cotisations
sociales qui nous font nous ouvrir des
droits ou est-ce que nous allons
continuer la bascule vers une
fiscalisation croissante qui fait que ce
sont les impôts nationaux mais aussi
locaux pour les prestations dette
sociale qui viennent financer une partie
de la protection sociale
bon trois derniers mots et la hm3 uv je
fais 4 p4c 3u c'est joli j'ai mes mots
techniques pour ceux qui ça intéresse
détroit est assez classique
un grand projet de protection sociale
c'était l'unification l'uniformisation
et l'universalisation universalisation
en fait la france est un pays c'est joli
à protection sociale universel en santé
de la mddt on peut penser ce que l'on
veut
jusqu à l'ensemble des complémentaires
tout le monde est pris en charge en
matière de retraite c'est également un
système universel qui que vous soyez si
vous avez passé plus de dix ans en
situation régulière sur le territoire
vous avez au moins le minimum vieillesse
sans qu'on est très loin dans
l'universalisation le sujet de
l'unification qui est dans les projets
on va unifier les prestations notamment
les prestations d'être social il ya
beaucoup beaucoup à faire et à
progresser
fall d'animaux celui l'uniformisation en
matière de retraite notamment le truc
bringuebalant de tous ces régimes et
branches dans tous les coins où plus
personne ne comprend rien sinon
structure bénéficie
disproportionnellement est le grand
sujet je pense que le grand sujet c'est
d'uniformiser d'égaliser si j'ose dire
le système de protection sociale voilà
quatre p4c 3u vous en avez eu pour votre
argent
merci pour ce pcu pc après cpe pcu merci
en tout cas pour ces réflexions et
notamment bien sûr surligne
l'uniformisation d'un ensemble de
systèmes vous avez rappelé sur le
système des retraites
plus de 37 régimes de retraite
aujourd'hui cette fameuse équité entre
le privé et le public qui fait débat
depuis plusieurs années alors je dirai
qui tu es qui a commencé à être mises en
place depuis la réforme 2010 et claque
une augmentation de cotisations pour la
fonction publique
en tout cas beaucoup en tout cas de
choses restent à faire aujourd'hui pour
plus de transparence d'équité pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens pour
continuer cette réflexion je passe sans
plus tarder la parole à frédéric bizarre
donc économiste spécialisé dans la
protection sociale notamment dans les
domaines de retraite mais également de
santé frédéric je te donne la parole
bien merci arnaud
mon robinet merci jean pierre door de
m'avoir invité je suis ravi parce qu on
essaie de brasser des idées donc on est
toujours heureux de pouvoir en faire
participer ceux qui dirigent le pays
probablement demain alors à falloir je
change un peu mon implantation parce que
quand on passe après quelqu'un de
brillant comme julien évidemment il a
dit l'essentiel est ce que ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est qu'elle
essayait de voir avec vous quelle
protection sociale on va avoir au 21ème
siècle
quand vous regardez l'histoire de france
depuis la révolution française vous
apercevez qu'il ya eu plusieurs
générations de systèmes de protection
sociale en fonction des mutations de
l'environnement et on est aujourd'hui
sur une de ces mutations historiques de
l'environnement économique et social
donc il s'agit pas de faire un
ajustement du modèle mais de trouver une
nouvelle génération de protection
sociale or ce qu'on fait depuis des
années 30 ans et qu'on essaie un petit
peu c'est l'équivalent de essayer de
chaussée du 36 quand nous fait du 40
quand vous revenez chez vous essayez de
le faire c'est pas évident mais c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire avec le système de
protection sociale donc ça marche pas
alors dans quel système de protection
sociale sommes-nous en deux mots le
système de 45 cm de 45 c'est un système
qui a voulu généraliser les assurances
sociales qui avait été créé quinze ans
plus tôt mais pas seulement
système de 45 c'est un projet politique
d'émancipation
je dirais individuel de création d'une
solidarité d'appartenance pour mieux
articuler la responsabilité collective
et la responsabilité individuelle ce
qu'ont voulu faire les pères fondateurs
s'est solidarisé la société et enrichir
la vie démocratique
quand on regarde trente ans après la
création de la sécurité sociale quel
succès quand tout comparer la la la la
la cité française en 45 ans 75
c'est difficile de conseil que ce projet
le seul problème c'est qu'on a
progressivement sous la contrainte
économique a abandonné le projet
politique sauf l'extension com a dit
julien de la protection de nos systèmes
d'assurance sociale mais on a abandonné
le reste et si vous regardez l'état de
la société française on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya un parallèle entre cet abandon du
projet politique et le délitement de la
société française la corrélation entre
les deux
tu es très bien démontré par plusieurs
sociologues et économistes
alors qu'est ce qui a changé dans ce
dans ce monde par rapport à 45
rapidement et par le triple transition
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui est un vieillissement démographique
pas un vieillissement physiologique nous
rajeunissons une génération à l'autre
les gens sont en meilleure santé à âge
égal ce qui est important en matière de
stratégie pour la santé mais ça a
évidemment un impact puisque on a plus
de 70% des dépenses sociales près de 500
milliards d'euros sur les 750 milliards
d'euros qui sont directs qui sont
directement ou indirectement dépendant
du vieillissement de la population
évidemment il faut le prendre en compte
la deuxième transition
c'est l'évolution des risques par
rapport aux systèmes au monde du système
de 45
en résumé on passe de risques courent
aleris que l'on 45 5 ans de durée de
retraite 2016 25 ans 45 principalement
des pathologies aiguës quelques jours
2016 pathologie chronique ça peut durer
des années
chômage structurel qui n'existaient pas
et juste le temps de trouver du travail
aujourd'hui à 2 millions de personnes au
chômage
donc on est sur un allongement de la
durée du risque qui est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle à l'exception de celui du
chômage mais le logiciel de gestion d'un
risque l'on est radicalement différent
de celui d'un risque cours l'état
providence sur un risque que l'on ça
marche pas je vais y revenir
troisième transition c'est la transition
technologique qui va nous permettre de
gérer les deux premières transition mais
qui impacte considérablement notamment
le marché du travail
les formes de travail là l'organisation
des carrières professionnelles plus en
plus discontinues ne plus en plus
diversifiée donc on voit que ce nouveau
monde là encore une fois impose pas de
changer le financement pas de faire
évoluer le financement pas des
ajustements par la métrique impose de
penser à une nouvelle génération de
protection sociale et quand je vous à
lens les programmes à ce jour où c'est
un peu la course à l'échalote de celui
qui fera le plus de dégressivité ou de
celui qui repoussera le plus tard
possible le
l'âge de l'entrée à la retraite tous
partis confondus
je me dis qu'on est loin du vrai
problème mais on a le temps est encore
un an
donc quel système de protection sociale
pour demain trois leviers le premier
donc d'abord ce qui est quand même de
pas mal c'est qu'on a créé une
république sur trois principes liberté
égalité solidarité fraternité qui sont
quand même les trois piliers de base et
on va dire idéaux pour construire un
système de protection sociale au 21ème
siècle qui fonctionne donc appuyons nous
sur ces trois piliers ya trois
évolutions affaire il ya un
l'universalisation dont a parlé
julien ça entraîne quoi ça entraîne un
transfert des droits sociaux du statut
professionnel à la personne peut appeler
d'individualisation des droits sociaux
vous savez que votre droit social n'est
pas lié vous n'avez pas droit social en
tant que personne mais en tant que
travailleur et c'est lié à votre statut
professionnel d'où tous ces régimes
il faut évidemment maintenant qu'on à
universaliser ces droits là il faut
prendre acte de sa et le faire quelle
conséquence c'est que vous créez un
régime universel de santé
vous créez un régime universel de
retraite mais pour faire ça et pour le
légitimer quelque part auprès de la
population
encore faut-il avoir fait évoluer ce
droit là il expliqué à la population
qu'elle intéresse a un fait un intérêt
pour diminuer considérablement les coûts
de gestion 1,36 régimes de retraite
quatorze régime de santé et pour
permettre aux gens qui ont des carrières
discontinues de passer d'un secteur à
l'autre tout en conservant une
protection sociale voyez que c'est
simple quand même ça ce principe là tout
le monde le comprend même un socialiste
peut le comprendre
non mais d'ailleurs madame touraine l'a
compris elle a créé le régime se sentent
et universal mais la juste se crée
l'étiquette parce que derrière on n'a
rien unifiée donc en fait pour le
citoyen de base
en fait on n'a rien progresser mais vous
avez le régime santé universel sans ce
qui va avec donc évidemment il y aura un
effet ça c'est une première étape
après c'est un peu plus compliqué il
faut aller vers un système qui
privilégie l'autonomie et la liberté
pourquoi
parce que pour gérer un risque selon
l'objectif d'un système de protection
sociale du 21e siècle c'est de rendre
les individus les plus autonomes
possible dans l'auto gestion de leurs
risques sociales y compris pour les plus
défavorisés
et c'est là où il faut faire basculer le
système
l'ancien monde système est à providence
vous transférez vous faites des
transferts financiers pour remplacer une
perte de revenus le nouveau monde vous
faites des transferts de capacité pour
rendre les gens pour les gens capables
de faire
alors ok ça ça paraît très théorique
concrètement le mont ruan mon régime
universel de retraite il vient ruraux
régime celle de retraite à points
pourquoi parce que quand j'ai un système
à points généralisée jeu permet aux gens
de constituer leurs oeufs à point c'est
comme votre système complémentaire de
retraite aujourd'hui où en fait vous
accumulez des points plutôt que des
annuités et au moment où vous avez vous
décidé de prendre votre retraite parce
qu'avec un système à points vous pouvez
plus facilement décider
et bien en fait en fonction de la valeur
du point on vous sert une retraite c'est
ce que vous avez dans le système
complémentaire pour les salariés donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui vous aide à
constituer votre retraite parce que vous
avez une visibilité et au moment de la
liquidation de votre retraite d'avoir
davantage de choix
vous êtes actif dernière dernier point
la démocratie sociale ça c'est quand
même une chose qui est assez
extraordinaire parce que les père
fondateur ont mis en place un système de
démocratie sociale
à une époque où franchement c'était pas
la priorité
ils ont été extrêmement visionnaire pour
ça alors comme le l'outil utilisé la
déclinaison de cette démocratie sociale
a été plus ou moins abandonné tout le
monde est d'accord pour le fait que ça
ne fonctionne plus quel système
paritaire
finalement on dit à quoi bon avoir une
démocratie sociale bon courage à ceux
qui vont être attisées système ce demain
donc cette démocratie sociale dans la
cyberculture dans laquelle on est elle a
jamais été autant d'actualité est
nécessaire maintenant c'est un impact
sur la gouvernance avec une règle simple
c'est que l'état fait décide de la
politique de protection sociale décide
de la politique des retraites décide de
la politique de santé fixe les règles du
jeu et laisse
la société civile dans la gouvernance de
la gestion la gestion courante du
système et cette division qui me paraît
importante quand une fois bon courage à
ceux qui vont vouloir que l'état fasse
tout on est sûr que dans mon avis
d'aller pas bien loin voilà ce que
j'avais à vous dire donc en conclusion
encore une fois la mutation profonde de
notre environnement fait qu'on doit
adapter nos modèles de société et en
particulier notre modèle de protection
sociale qui est un des piliers c'est
indispensable pour établir la confiance
ce qui est pas la moindre des choses à
rétablir confiance avec ceux qui nous
dirigent avec les politiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ont pris
conscience qu'ils avaient une mutation
profonde et ce qui constate c'est que
les systèmes n'évolue pas ce qui est
donc on peut comprendre un petit peu que
quand vous leur parler ils ont perdu un
petit peu de confiance je parle aux
hommes politiques qui m'entourent donc
ça c'est un signe fort de renvoyer et ça
permet de maîtriser les dépenses
sociales pour maîtriser les dépenses
sociales faut maîtriser la demande
sociale donc il faut un système qui soit
efficace
je vous assure qu'après le financement
c'est facile merci merci merci frédéric
pour continuer ses réflexions je passe
sans plus tarder la parole à bernard
accoyer
merci merci arnaud bon c'est un exercice
bien difficile devant une assemblée
d'experts qui est réuni ce matin ici aux
républicains côté de nos cerveaux que
sont eric woerth
en tout cas ils aiment bien qu'on le lui
dise comme ça et arnaud qui essayent de
l'égaler donc je vais faire très très
très modeste et souligné la modestie du
programme qui veut simplement en
quelques minutes refonder notre modèle
social pour refonder
c'est un terme assez flou mais modèle
social la question c'est avons nous
vraiment en france un modèle social
digne de ce nom
encore aujourd'hui qu'est-il devenu en
70 ans où il a oublié de se réformer
alors que cela vienne nous être rappelé
par frédéric brizard tout a changé tout
a basculé
tout a muté et doux en bon français en
ariège changé
en tout cas peu de choses la réforme la
plus importante a été la réforme de 1976
on se souvient combien la vérité
douloureuse elle a été profonde parce
que avant 76 avait même pas de budget de
la sécurité sociale est la plus grosse
masse financière qui chaque année est en
mouvement n'était soumise
aucun vote parlementaire il manquait de
l'argent à la fin de l'exercice on n'en
rajoutait et puis ça suffisait je ne
vais pas parler tout parce que c'est pas
l'envié qui manque c'est pas des sujets
qui sont inintéressants la famille on
voit ce que donnent les mesures qui ont
été prises contre l'aide à toutes les
familles avec la fiscalisation le
quotient familial
on voit les résultats immédiatement
c'est la baisse de la natalité est dans
un système de solidarité
intergénérationnelle
c'est exactement ciller la branche sur
laquelle on est assis
je ne vais pas vous parler des retraites
parce que j'ai déjà beaucoup donné mon
cher eric lorsque en 2010 on a essayé de
réformer
il s'en est fallu de peu que nous
réformions points et je me rappelle
quand tu me faisait des signes pour me
dire de ne surtout pas passer en force
et bien heureusement que je suis passé
en force
parce qu'en regardant ce qui se passe
dans les rues aujourd'hui eh bien je
pense que nous aurions fait comme les
autres
on aurait baissé le drapeau et on serait
parti gentiment a prévu 15 jours de
suspension des travaux puisque ce qui
était près c'était ce qui était prévu
c'est dire que réformés et compliqué
mais je vais vous parler un peu de santé
parce que c'est quand même ma vie etc
avant de rentrer dans ce monde politique
qui est souvent très décevant
j'ai eu et j'ai toujours cette passion
pour la santé est finalement y at il une
préoccupation sur le président du
conseil national de l'ordre mais chers
confrères
y at il une préoccupation plus
prioritaires pour chacun d'entre nous et
pour chaque français que leur santé ou
celle de ceux qui leur sont chers
la réponse est évidemment non et bien
pourtant les gouvernements
successivement n'ont pas compris qu'il
fallait adapter en permanence notre
système de soins notre système de
couverture maladie et on en est arrivé à
une situation qui est à bout de souffle
à bout de souffle alors la décision la
plus stupidement technocratique que l'on
n'ait jamais connue dans notre pays
c'est le numerus clausus c'est la
décision péremptoire qui part du
principe que plus on forme de
professionnels plus on dépense et donc
il y aura des déficits et au lieu de
réformer ce système bon ben on étouffe
le dispositif qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
des milliers des milliers de nos jeunes
compatriotes qui avait une passion
depuis qu'il était enfant voit après
qu'ils aient échoué en première année
arrivée des professionnels formés dans
des pays où le niveau n'est pas le même
c'est un scandale mais venons en aux en
plus simplement un chacun chacun des
sujets toutes et à toutes les tares voir
tout est à revoir
parce qu'on a laissé le système se
déresponsabiliser se socialiser
s'autodétruire et à chaque fois qu'il y
à une mesure qui est prise c'est une
mesure qui crée une boîte vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure
frédéric ii le régime d'assurance
maladie universelle ça les socialistes
ils ont créé des tiers payant de tous
les côtés des systèmes de
déresponsabilisation qu'il baptise
toujours universelle elle résultat il
est là et la vérité est que nous ne
sommes jamais nous la droite jamais
revenu sur les erreurs qui avaient été
commis c'est donc notre responsabilité
est en la matière évidente bon chacun
sait que pour ce qui est de son
financement
le financement de la protection sociale
et par conséquence de l'assurance
maladie est devenue totalement inadapté
aujourd'hui on taxe la production on axe
de travail et on laisse une consommation
effrénée
on nous parle d'un consumérisme qui
déstructure menacerait notre
environnement
il est évident qu'il faut faire basculer
une part du financement sociale sur la
consommation
en créant alors si on veut être
maladroit politiquement on parle de la
tva sociale
donc on va en parler puisque on ne loupe
jamais une occasion d'être maladroit
mais il faudrait plutôt parler de
contribution sociale ça c'est des mots
qui passe bien contribution sociale sur
la consommation
c'est juste la même chose que la csg
mais c'est sur la consommation
ça concerne les produits d'importation
ça allège le coût des productions sur le
territoire national évidemment que cette
voie devra être mise en place
progressivement parce qu'on ne peut en
france rien changé brutalement et c'est
bien dommage en tout cas il faut y aller
on avait essayé de le faire avant 2012
mais on l'avait fait à crédit et on
avait prévu de le mettre en oeuvre
après les élections ou après l'élection
présidentielle et les élections
législatives
on sait ce qu'il en est advenu sur le
financement je dirais de mon du
financement des de la vieillesse il est
évident que en se coupant du financement
capitalistique terre d'un régime
capitalistique de vieillesse on a
contribué très largement à faire partir
les centres de décision à faire prendre
le contrôle par des fonds de pension
étrangers de toutes nos pépites
industriels et ça continue si en 83 au
lieu d'avoir mis la retraite à 60 ans on
avait décidé de créer un fonds
d'investissement fonds de réserve
eh bien la france serait un pays qui
détiendrait une grande partie du système
industriel et de production européens et
probablement au delà
bon il n'est jamais trop tard pour
essayer de se rattraper
revenons-en à la santé je vous ai dit
que sur la formation sur le recrutement
sur la médecine ambulatoire
il me semble que on oublie que la
médecine libérale cher président dans la
médecine libérale il y a le mot libéral
or que se passe-t-il tout étant fermés
on a en 1981 avec quelques-uns qui s'en
souviennent et j'en étais créer un petit
espace de liberté liberté la liberté
c'est la médecine libérale et penser
qu'on pourrait sauver le système de
soins français tels que les français se
le sont approprié est telle qu'ils y
sont attachés sans qu'il y ait cet
espace de liberté est une illusion est
une utopie
il y à une exigence de des espaces de
liberté
harry faire si on veut faire survivre le
système je le dis je les assume
parce que je suis aux antipodes de ce
qui est en train de faire le système
avec en particulier la conquête que
l'assurance maladie complémentaire est
en train d'exercer sur la liberté
tarifaire et je le dit avec vraiment
beaucoup de solennité
les contrats qui ont été baptisés
solidaires et responsables sont un outil
qui enferme complètement le système de
financement des soins dans une boîte qui
finira évidemment par une totale
socialisation collectivisation c'est à
dire qu'il y aura une médecine à
plusieurs étages avec des régime
surcomplémentaire c'est inévitable
encore une fois parce que quand on est
malade on a envie de disposer des soins
qui soit à la hauteur sur sur le sur
l'hôpital ont un peu dans le désordre
tout ça parce que non seulement la bonne
chose à dire ouais super mais je parle
pas souvent sur l'hôpital sur l'hôpital
l'évaluation on n'évalue pas les
réformes de structure le privé chez le
président de la fédération hospitalière
privée le privé on est en train
d'assassiner l'hospitalisation privée
quand on aura fini d'assassiner à
l'hospitalisation privée
ce sera à l'hôpital ce sont les listes
d'attentes la baisse du niveau du niveau
des soins ce qui sera évidemment une
catastrophe
le l'irruption des élus locaux et des
élus politiques dans la carte
hospitalière est une erreur fondamentale
tant qu'on continuera comme ça et je
sais que mes collègues sont pas d'accord
mais je m'en fous
et tant qu'on continuera comme ça on
n'arrivera à rien réformer parce que
vous regardez le petit service de ceux
ci le petit service de ceux là l'hôpital
doit évidemment sur le plan d urgence
travailler avec la médecine libérale
conventionnés avec des cabinets libéraux
qui doivent être multi multiplient
disciplinaire comme on dit ça me paraît
une évidence absolue
bon je sens que mes collègues sont en
train de s'énerver parce que je parle
trop
longtemps donc je vais peut-être
m'arrêter ben je vois bien que vous êtes
un petit peu plus vous voulez que je
continue à madame greffe pas que je
continue
faut-il que je continue voilà madame
bref bien je vais t'apprendre la
démocratie tu as
bon bref nous devons être fidèles à nos
convictions la liberté la concurrence la
qualité l'évaluation l'accès aux
nouvelles technologies
les financements de lits médecine mosher
qui valencien la codification de ses
actes innovant le développement et la
rétribution de la chirurgie ambulatoire
dans lequel le spitz avion privé public
est en retard de façon colossale sur le
privé et surtout ne pas avoir un
dogmatisme anti privé faire travailler
le public et le privé
avoir des médecins qui ont un statut
comme je les ai eues dans le passé un
statut des deux côtés à l'hôpital et en
ville et une fois qu'on aura réuni tous
à faire aussi en sorte que et j'aurais
dû commencer par là
l'accès aux études de médecine l'accès
aux professions de santé par les études
qui conduisent soit révisée revue
régionaliser adaptés aux besoins locaux
et surtout aux aspirations de nos pays
merci merci bernard nous faire partager
tes convictions avec autant de dynamisme
c'est un vrai programme présidentiel ce
que tu nous présentes
est-ce que ça annonce une candidature
éric lavoie qui ont lui ressembler si
j'ai bien compris c'est dit bernard
accoyer et pardonnez moi d'être arrivé
en retard
j'avais une maître matinale comme on dit
de de télévision je voulais dire juste
un mot parce que le les tables rondes
qui viennent sont très lourd donc
juste un petit mot d'abord sur le
financement puis on a commencé par ça et
puis on va évidemment
branchez les tables rondes sur le
contenu des choses mais bernard a parlé
beaucoup de sujets sur le financement il
est impossible de continuer à financer
un modèle de protection sociale au sens
large du terme sur le dos des
générations futures
c'est juste pas possible on peut faire
plein de choses sur le dos des
générations futures on peut investir
mais on peut pas on peut pas financer un
modèle de protection sociale
et si aujourd'hui le cas c'est un
problème je pense d'éthique et de morale
de chaque génération de s'assumer et
d'assumer son modèle de protection
sociale et de d2 santé ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui il faut donc rompre avec
cette spirale infernale et qui est d'une
brutalité inouïe vis-à-vis des
générations futures
alors il faut évidemment réformer et le
principe du financier c'est que c'est
les les conséquences des différentes
réformes je vous prends un exemple on
propose de limiter la progression de
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie ce qu'on appelle
l'ondam so foot combien augmente les
dépenses on en a un objectif il est voté
chaque année par le le parlement ya pas
de sanction particulière si on ne le
respecte pas enfin ça permet d'encadrer
les choses il faut limiter on donne des
chiffres 1 75%
ça veut dire que les dépenses de santé
elles iront toujours un tout petit peu
plus vite que les dépenses
d'accroissement de notre richesse
nationale
ça veut dire ça parce qu on est plus
nombreux parce que les technologies sont
plus fortes
donc ça nécessite évidemment en ce
moment là de viser une une adaptation du
financement de notre protection sociale
en tout cas un ondam de plus en plus
contraints et de plus en plus mesuré
pour y parvenir il faut réformer et je
pense que bernard l'a très bien dit il
faut réformer à la fois l'hôpital grande
source de dépenses il faut évidemment
donné à l'hôpital tous lés moyens de
soigner les soins les plus aigus mais on
voit bien que beaucoup de choses doivent
être faites
ils peuvent être faites en dehors de
l'hôpital c'est le cas pour beaucoup de
pays l'hôpital d'ailleurs tente de le
faire donc c'est pas une découverte mais
encore faut-il le faire
et puis il faut aussi évidemment
renforcer la médecine libérale
il faut limiter les coûts de structure
de nombreuses caisses notamment
donc il ya beaucoup de sujets qui
relèvent de cela et puis limiter le coût
des affections de longue durée qui
aujourd'hui explique la plupart de la
progression de la dépense non pas en soi
néanmoins bien évidemment les personnes
qui sont ce qui peut arriver absolument
à tout le monde
il ya des personnes dans cette salle qui
sont certainement en à elle dès qu'il
faut donc faire en sorte que au travers
de la prévention au travers de contrats
on puisse mieux canaliser ses dépenses
pour le bien de tout le monde au delà de
l'ondam moi je suis assez favorable à un
système un peu brutal un peu pas très
intelligent il faut pas un gros cerveau
pour l'inventer c'est de se dire qu'il
faut interdire les déficits des branches
de sécurité sociale voilà que vous avez
dit ça c'est pas génial parce que vous
avez essayé de placer le curseur comme
ça c'est d'une brute la poste un peu
bêta c'est compliqué à mettre en place
mais je pense que c'est la seule manière
d'obliger à la réforme
vous vous imposez le fait qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir de déficit alors pouvait
raisonner par cycle évidemment il peut
pas y avoir de déficit de la des
branches de la sécurité sociale et à ce
moment-là partir du moment où vous
constatez où le parlement constate à un
moment donné ces déficits y ait des
mécanismes de stabilisation automatique
qui se met en place des mécanismes qui
font certainement plaisir à personne
mais ils sont justement fait pour me
faire plaisir à personne et un projet à
la réforme
ou alors un projet aussi à des modes de
financement plus adapté donc il faut
interdire les déficits de sécurité
sociale pour toutes les raisons que j'ai
indiquées enfin en ce qui concerne les
retraites qui est un élément très
important évidemment du volume de
dépenses après l'assurance maladie
bernard tout à l'heure a dit que ça ait
failli mal se terminer en 2010 c'est
vrai
on était sa pas fait ce n'était pas la
retraite par points c'était la retraite
par coup de poing et bernard acoyer a
failli s'en prendre quand même dans la
figure de la part de tous les démocrates
de gauche qui nous entoure est à
l'époque en décidant de cesser la
discussion à l'assemblée pour des
raisons de règlements internes et on
voit bien que les retraites comme tous
ces sujets sont extraordinairement
sensible et sur les retraites il faut
évidemment probablement basculer un
moment donné sur des régimes par points
parce que ça permet de fusionner les
différents régimes mais il faut surtout
surtout continuer à augmenter l'âge de
la retraite en fonction de l'espérance
de vie
c'est une évidence c'est un source
évidemment de grandes de grands
équilibres financiers et aujourd'hui si
le régime général va pas trop mal ça va
pas durer mais s'il va pas trop mal
c'est bien parce qu'on a réformé tous là
au bon moment mais il faut poursuivre
tout cela en évidemment tentant de
l'améliorer il faut donner une
visibilité aussi aux gens parce que
quand on prépare sa retraite on aimerait
bien savoir à quel âge on apprend donc
faut donner une visibilité et pas
prendre les gens et évidemment comme sa
part par défaut il faut être clair là
dessus nous affichons une clarté très
forte en ce qui concerne les régimes de
retraite voilà je vais m'arrêter là
mais la mesure forte que qu'on pourrait
être amené à proposer c'est
l'interdiction des déficits de la
sécurité sociale obligeant à des
corrections automatiques
ces corrections automatiques obligeant
évidemment systématiquement à se poser
des questions de fond merci
merci eric on a vu cette première table
ronde a permis également de poser les
jalons pour les tables rondes suivantes
puisque au delà du financement la
protection sociale et du sujet des
retraites
nous avons également abordé le sujet de
la santé qui est en tout cas un enjeu
est une préoccupation première pour nos
concitoyens et sur la santé il ya certes
il faut parler bien sûr aux
professionnels mais également parlé à
nos concitoyens parce que c'est une de
leurs premières préoccupations alors
merci messieurs pour vos interventions
merci d'avoir participé à notre
réflexion
en tout cas moi je suis heureux parce
que je crois que j'étais du timing de la
table ronde
9h20 voilà je pense et donc je passe je
passe le témoin à mon collègue et ami
jean pierre door dont député du loiret
maire de montargis sur la deuxième table
ronde ont qui va aborder le sujet de la
modernisation du système de santé
merci à vous